.
Les détails avec Alexandre
Duval.
- Chose promise, chose due.
Dès demain, six transporteurs
aériens mettront en vente des
billets à 500 $ pour les voyages
personnels dans les régions
du Québec. Il y en aura tout
près de 100 000 par année.
FRANÇOIS BONNARDEL, minis
des Transports du Québec
- Honnêtement, là, ce sera
un franc succès si on réussit,
puis je le souhaite.
Vendre ces 98 000 billets
sur une année complète.
- Ces billets seront disponibles
pour les vols au départou à dess
aéroports : Québec, Montréal
et Saint-Hubert.
Pour les voyageurs des régions
éloignées, comme l'Abitibi,
le Saguenay, la Côte-Nord
ou la Gaspésie, qui voyageront
sans passer par l'un des trois
principaux aéroports, un autre
programme remboursera jusqu'à
60 % du coût de leur billet.
- Il y en a quand même plusieurs
qui m'ont demandé : Pourquoi
ceci? Pourquoi pas cela?
Alors nous, ce qui était
important, c'était de s'assurer
de bonifier et d'assurer
la pérennité de ces desserte
dans les prochaines années.
- Lors de leur achat,
les voyageurs devrger
à respecter la limite annuelle
de trois allers-retours à 500 $
ou six allers simples à 250 $.
Une offre alléchante pour bien
des gens...
KARINE DUMAS,
résidente de Rimouski
- Ma soeur, elle vit
à La Romaine et je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion d'aller la voirencors
années, parce que c'est très
onéreux. C'était très onéreux.
Fait que oui, c'est sûr
que ça encourage beaucoup.
- Mais pour d'autres,
comme cette résidente
des Îles-de-la-Madeleine,
il pourrait y avoir des effets
indésirables.
ALICIA VIGNEAU, résidente
des Îles-de-la-Madeleine
- Il y a déjà assez de touristes
qui viennent l'été, donc
ce serait bien si on pouvait
étendre la saison touristique
sur toute l'année à la place.
SYLVAIN DICAIRE, directeur
des finances, Air Creebec
- Là, présentement, la demande,
on en a besoin.
- Les transporteurs aériens
espèrent que le programme
ramènera des voyageurs
après la période difficile
de la pandémie. Mais déjà, ils
anticipent que la compensation
offerte par le gouvernement
entre le tarif à 500 $
et le coût réel du billet
devra être revue à la haus
YANI GAGNON, copropriétaire,
Pascan Aviation
- Le prirant a triplé
sur 12 mois, a doublé depuis le
début de la guerre en Ukraine.
- Les transporteurs aériens
sont prêts à donner une chance
à ce programme qui est doté
d'une enveloppe de 38 millions
rs pour l'année à venir.
Mais si le volume de passagers
n'est pas au rendez-vous,
certains n'hésiteront pas
à mettre un terme à leur
participation.
Ici Alexandre Duval, Radio-Cané